merci bonsoir même de 24,60 bon sens mal
du tout enseignant pendant plusieurs
décennies
sociologue de renom monsieur rocher vous
êtes un des bâtisseurs de la révolution
des artisans de cette révolution
tranquille vous avez refait le parcours
historique de l'évolution du québec
aujourd'hui ils vous inscrivez ce projet
de loi dans la continuité historique et
vous regardez beaucoup vers l'avenir
pour quelles raisons principalement
défendez-vous ce projet de loi je les
défends je les banques parce que une
fois de plus l'assemblée nationale avec
ce projet de loi est appelé à intervenir
dans la laïcisation du système
d'éducation
je n'ai pas la première fois que
l'assemblée nationale ne sera au
contraire l'assemblée nationale était
venue de multiples fois depuis plus de
50 ans pour la halle pour la saisie le
système d'éducation du québec
on peut remonter à 1960 quand
l'assemblée nationale clé le ministère
de l'éducation c'était le début la
laïcisation et surtout qu'un le médecin
de l'éducation et à créer les que
l'assemblée nationale et le messin de
situation auquel et les cégep et
l'université du québec comme institution
publique et laïque
et puis par la suède jusque 1 2 mais à
peu près l'assemblée nationale a été
appelée à plusieurs moments a contribué
à la laïcisation du système d'éducation
du québec
donc ce projet de loi il n'arrive pas
comme une surprise
au contraire il se situe dans toutes les
interventions de l'assemblée nationale
qui depuis plus de 50 ans ont participé
contribuer activement à la laïcisation
du québec
donc on ne peut pas dire que ce projet
de loi va à l'encontre de l'histoire du
québec
au contraire ce projet de loi s'inscrit
dans la démocratie que la cua voulu la
société québécoise la démocratie
scolaire en particulier
de tupi ses craintes c'est donc un
projet de loi qui que je trouve que je
viens défendre parce que ils connaissent
po1 tous les efforts que tous les
acteurs très nombreux ont fait depuis
plus de 60 ans pour assurer que notre
système d'éducation et l'est en vue
d'être démocratique en ville étant donné
mes classiques vous parler du principe
de précaution qu on entend généralement
matière environnementale ou de santé
publique qu'est ce que ça vient faire
dans l'éducation
est ce que ça vient faire c'est que ce
pain se veut dire que dans les
certitudes parce que là nous sommes dans
l'incertitude concernant la supposée où
nos influences de l'enseignant ou des cd
ou des signes ostentatoires religieux
pour le sud sur les élèves sur les
étudiants même sur les parts on ne sait
pas et là dessus je suis bien obligé de
dire là dessus de mon ami jacques
bouchard qu' il n'est pas tim en
scientifiquement impossible de faire des
preuves scientifiques valable parce que
méthodologiquement cette recherche n'est
pas possible ciel avait été passé dans
la réception longtemps et donc le
principe de précaution vient dire que
d'un dans une incertitude
il faut s'assurer que l'eau on va vers
le minimum de risques et ainsi concerne
les signes ostentatoires d'appartenance
à une religion c'est de dire que mais il
faut éviter que ceux ci n'existe que si
sa présence chez des élèves pour éviter
un prosélytisme possible pour éviter une
influence religieuse possible pour
éviter aussi conflits possibles entre
les deux conditions de jeu zde parent et
et celle de
d'enseignant à l'école parce que
maintenant nous vivons dans une société
très fragmenté au point de vue religieux
de ce que demain devant la classe dans
une classe l'enseignant et devant des
enfants dont les parents peuvent être
témoins de jéhovah peut-être mort mon
poste et évangéliste parce qu'être
catholique parce que d'autres choses
encore as tu es donc et il est important
de s'assurer que ce principe de
précaution est utilisé dans ce code non
cet état d'incertitude dans laquelle ce
qu'on entend le plus souvent des
opposants que l'on rencontre même au gré
des rencontres publiques déjà qu'on
rencontre des courriels qu'on l'iodé se
posent la question en quoi
l'interdiction du port de signes
religieux est nécessaire parce que les
enfants voient les gens là vivent cette
pluralité dans la société de plus en
plus le québec d'aujourd'hui n'est pas
celui d'il ya 50 ans d'ailleurs
quelqu'un qui a twitté aujourd'hui je
pense que vous étiez un homme d'un autre
siècle pour que vous avez reçue seul
mais à quoi l'interdiction du port de
signes religieux ajoute à l'égalité et
n'est pas discriminatoire comme les
opposa le soutien de la répétition parce
que ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
les religions ne sont pas égales j'ai
des régions plus riches que d'odieux des
religions confuse d'adhérents que
d'autres il ya des régions qui sont plus
fortes que d'autres et il ya des
religions qui sont plus visibles que
d'autres le catholicisme était très
longtemps la religion la plus visible au
québec de toutes les manières avec toute
l'école natif le tan les processus
recteur a suivi les protestations
le destin de john et de données de votre
depuis que l'église catholique a connu
le déclic elle connaît ou n'est plus la
place de blé n'a ce qui arrive en ce
moment il se trouve qu'en ce moment
c'est la religion de l'islam qui est
plus visible que les autres religions et
les femmes dans l'islam aussi parce que
ses 16 ans était en carton se pose au
projet de loi
et il se trouve que ce sont des femmes
comme il se trouve que dans des écoles
primaires d'autres fois c'était des
femmes c'était des religieuses y avait
presque pas d'un homme qui essayait
d'arrêter les mêmes d'autrefois
donc aujourd'hui c'est un peu la même
chose
à cet égard de l'enseignement attire
particulièrement des femmes à ce niveau
là est ce que l'on peut dire pour
l'avenir qui s'en vient c'est que nous
vivons dans une société qui vont être de
plus en plus fragmenté chocolat
religieux nous nous ne connaîtrons plus
l'unité religieuse que nous avons connue
autrefois c'est fini et non ce dans ce
paysage le ligier fragmenté ce qui est
important c'est que une religion ne soit
pas favorisé par rapport aux autres mais
pourquoi les est content maintenant
terminée oui oui quand il se trouve que
l'islande en ce moment risque d'être
plus favorisés que d'autres parce
qu'elle est plus visible c'est la
responsable de l'islam c'est si on veut
d'être le plus visible mais la société
n'est pas obligé d'accepter ça et ce
n'est pas discriminatoire c'est même ça
pourrait même est discriminatoire pour
les autres minorités religieuses de
d'accepter qu'une religion soit dans
l'école plus présente beaucoup plus
présente et si on va vers l'avenir
peut-être de plus en plus pressants qui
est possible que l'islam soit la région
de plus en plus présente
ou bien on peut bien prévoir qu'une
autre religion les témoins de jéhovah
seront plus présents donc il ya un prêt
c'est pas mon avis d'égalité très
important projet d'égalité des minorités
religieuses les minorités religieuses
dit j'ai plusieurs représentants de
régions étaient exclus de cette
consultation la semaine dernière et le
déplore et c'est parce qu'elle soutienne
ses sens les principales personnes qui
s'opposent au projet de loi en disant ça
stigmatise ça détruit sur la commission
scolaire anglophone va défendre
aujourd'hui que ça détruit des rêves
c'est un obstacle à l'intégration des
immigrants même des immigrants madame
plan disait qu'il ya peut-être une
égalité entre hommes et femmes ça
pourrait nuire davantage aux femmes
est ce que ces gens là n'ont pas des
craintes légitimes
ce sont des craintes que je que je
respecte beaucoup mais ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que nous avons voulu
depuis plus de 50 ans
respecter l'école publique commune et
cela c'est très important parce que moi
j'aimerais dire à une enseignante qui
veut porter des signes ostentatoires
regardez bien la classe à laquelle vous
voulez essayer vous êtes vous bien que
vous avez devant vous des enfants dont
les parents ont aussi des convictions
religieuses aussi forte que les vôtres
vous avez des parents qui sont
probablement à t on avait des paraphes
sur mornant vous avez par exemple moi
j'ouvre et qui ont des convictions
religieuses aussi forte que les ventres
or est-ce que vous c'est vous qui devez
demander qu'on respecte vous vous vos
convictions le geste ou est ce que dans
une école publique payés par les fonds
publics
ce n'est pas vous vous comme enseignants
qui devaient respecter les étudiants que
vous avez devant vous respectez les
les professeurs d'autant plus que si
vous sentez dans l'enseignement vous y
entrez pour un bon nombre d'années je
sais je vous le souhaite et donc pendant
un bon nombre d'années
vous allez de 20 des élèves dont les
parents n'appartient pas à votre groupe
religieux et ce sont ses parents qui ont
de droit de s'attendre à ce que l'enfant
qui l'inscrivent dans l'école publique
ne soit dans une école vraiment mende ou
une religion n'est pas plus n'est pas
présente plus que toute saison
dans cette logique là est-ce qu'il ya
pas d incohérence à savoir que ça ne
s'applique qu'à l'école publique et en
ne l'étant pas l'école privée
subventionnée et certains sous soulève
le risque que ça favorise l'école privée
subventionnée
je suis bien d'accord avec vous je vais
bien voulu personnellement que la loi
s'étendent aux écoles privées
subventionnées au moins des écoles
privées subventionnées
j'avais bien vu que c'est un dossier au
cp1 j'aurais bien voulu que c'est dans
cette rue personnel de l'école y compris
des psychologues y compris le personnel
administratif donc assez d g cette loi
loin d'être le radical non seulement
elle est modérée je dirais qu'elle est
trop modéré je dirais comme on allume
mon ami louis bernard c'est une loi
minimale et donc et elle comporte des
incohérences
parce qu'elle ne veut pas au bout de ce
qu'elle aurait dû faire donc je
jason jeu vient appuyer ce projet de loi
mais je l'appuie conditionnellement
parce que je trouve qu'il ne va pas
assez loin
bon alors en terminant monsieur rocher
les craintes exprimées ou les effets
possibles de cette loi là sur la
division possible entre québécois
francophones et les autres parce qu on
reproche beaucoup au gouvernement d'en
faire un projet identitaire est ce qu'il
ya dans vos motivations des
modifications des motivations
identitaires également ou pas non pas du
tout mais je pense que par ailleurs si
ce projet de loi est appliquée comme je
l'espère je pense que cela va aider les
relations entre la majorité qui
n'appartient pas aux populations
millions ou le jeu minoritaires et les
religions ne t'ai pas ce que vous savez
si on laisse les choses aller sur permet
à des enseignants de plus en plus à un
parti de plus en plus de signes
ostentatoires en plus grand nombre
on risque un malaise entre la majorité
et les religions minoritaires
c'est ce qui m'inquiète personnellement
je suis bien plus inquiet de l'avenir si
ses demandes n'étaient pas n'étaient pas
sanctionnés s'ils n'étaient pas
appliquées parce que je ne suis pas
certain du tout de ce qui peut se passer
tandis que surtout avec le type la
clause dérogatoire on va permettre à ce
projet doit de commencer être appliquée
et de voir comment ils s'appliquent et
dans quelle mesure on peut l'appliquer
en limitant le plus possible la
discrimination et et dans un esprit
d'égalité de toutes les communes de
toutes les religions minoritaires et de
bons rapports entre la majorité
québécoise éliminer la communauté
scolaire anglophone semblé s'entendre je
vais pas faire d'erreur de faire mais ça
laisse entendre qu'avec plusieurs ont
dit que ce sera difficile d'applications
eu peut-être que red du mal à
l'appliquer mais ils ont témoigné devant
le comité parlementaire là comme ça
parlementaire que la laïcité est une
nouvelle religion c'est bien d'étonnant
c'est comme on peut dire que le
communisme et une à une nouvelle
religion
je pense que la laïcité c'est loin
d'être une religion c'est au contraire
la manière de respecter toutes les
religions c'est tout c'est même en
dehors de religion c'est la manière là
mon avis il est plus politique la plus
sociale de spectre tout et de dijon de
la favoriser aucune dent à n'imposer
aucune et de de s'assurer que dans une
société de plus en plus fragmenté en ont
vite avec une certaine égalité est
vraiment vraiment rentré dans cette fois
ci comme je m'adresse bien sûr au
sociologue que vous êtes grand
observateur de l'évolution de la société
québécoise
comment vous expliquer alors maintenant
un tel clivage devant des arguments
rationnels de part et d'autre qui ne se
rencontrent pas ces presses qui
réconcilia comment vous l'expliquer
parce que je pense que c'est un touchant
avec ce projet de loi aspects de la
société québécoise importante son
rapport le rapport de l'état avec les
religions et cela n'est pas n'est pas un
problème un film au contraire c'est une
c'est un grand problème tout comme la
société québécoise s'est pas réalisé
lorsque nous avons présenté le projet de
loi sur la langue française un président
doit sa je le trouve aujourd'hui une
polarisation qui ressemble beaucoup à
celle de cette époque là parce que la
loi 101 était une loi qui touchait la
population d'un de ses faibles la langue
maintenant nous touchons là la
population dans une autre zone aussi
fiable c'est les convictions en matière
de religion et en ce moment cette
question à une certaine prédominance je
marque et que si on la touche à la loi
salle on aurait peut-être une autre sauf
de prod2 polarisation pour une fois ces
patients ce moment des lois sont un peu
en retrait que écueil est
malheureusement une grande indifférence
dans la population québécoise un endroit
de la langue que nous sommes dans la
paix linguistique en semences qui surgit
c'est la question de l'hygiène et à la
sueur de l'alto nom de nos évolutions du
québec qui est propre au québec et
particulier au québec depuis cinquante
là dessus monsieur guy rocher merci
beaucoup d'être passé en studio
aujourd'hui au revoir merci